for originality creativity
and
exploration you really can't beat what's
happening on television now in all of
its forms
why is writing tv better than writing
movies
television is the place for innovation
now
it's the most exciting area
for people who want to create originally
i know that's in contradiction to
the tradition where people thought well
independent films was me expressing my
voice and my idea actually
television has so much opportunity now
that there are many many ways to tell
your story or to tell any story
and i think just the plethora of
opportunity
is part of what makes it great the other
thing that makes it great is that you
can do the long narrative
that uh in writing a movie if it's a
two-hour movie your story really has to
end in 90 minutes or 120 minutes or even
if it's a little bit flexible from that
with television you can tell a six-hour
story an eight-hour story a 13-hour
story a 26-hour story or a story that
lasts 100 hours
and that means
that you can expand vertically
by that what i mean is not that the plot
goes on and on
but that the depth of character is
something that you can continue to
reveal
and
secrets keep coming out over the many
many hours of a show and it's a
different kind of creating it's a little
bit more like life
in the sense that life doesn't end in
two hours or it doesn't end when a plot
comes to the point that something
concludes or finishes it's uh it's the
continuity of experience and
uh all of that is some of what uh
television offers now
and then i guess the the only downside
would be that you would have to test
your story to make sure that it does
have legs to be more than
90 minutes
well in creating a show
uh
a an episodic television show as opposed
to for example a movie movie for
television or even a limited series um
in doing a longer
s series
what you need to do is conceive of it at
the beginning
to make sure that it has legs and
springboards and by that i mean
that the story uh has a potential
to continue having generating
other stories as it goes along mostly
propelled by the the characters in the
cast
springboards also means that uh each
episode whether it's an hour or a half
hour or whatever length it is uh needs
something that springs it forward uh
whereas in a movie you might have
you know a continuous a plot that starts
with you know whatever the uh inciting
moment is at the beginning has a certain
number of plot points or changes and
comes to a conclusion and that's really
too simple for what television is so the
the complexity uh is something you bring
to it uh from the very very start it's
not something you find later
how is writing a television show
different from writing a movie
writing for television
is uh faster
and more specific in terms of
getting the uh internal motor going for
the characters
the process if you're on an actual show
does have to do with deadlines you have
to write fast enough
that if you are doing multiple episodes
of a show
that you're on schedule so
the idea of uh
the artist in the garrett waiting for a
muse to strike is not going to work if
you're writing for television uh you
really have to turn out the work
i find that that's actually energizing
to
the creative process rather than
deadening i think the idea that somebody
is waiting for what you have
and that there's a lit just that little
bit of pressure on you to deliver
sometimes helps you actually get to work
and to pull out what you need to do
writing from movies
i don't know how much this
industry even exists anymore there are
two ways that people write for movies
now one is that you're on a blockbuster
franchise
and that's
i
that's writing
but it's writing to a formula
that is somebody else's and it is also
uh means you're part of a team which is
essentially director and producer driven
or sometimes even star driven
so that you're
the chance for you to exercise your
creativity is
is within those parameters i wouldn't
say it's gone it's never gone you can
always give whatever you can and bring
whatever you can to the story and the
characters
but i find that uh to me uh that's
limiting the other kind of writing for
for movies or theatrical features uh is
the indie process
the indie process is not a business the
indie process means you need to finance
your own
material
and you go to the art festivals
the end product of doing indie
films is that you might get hired to
work on television
because there is
not much business there in other words
how many people are going to see some
small indie film unless you can get it
on netflix because now
the
boundary between what is a movie and
what is television is is certainly
graying if not eroding completely
almost all of the premium outlets are
doing uh what i call the shorter form
which is the two hour form or even
90-minute form
as well as much longer in fact things
are in all sorts of sizes now you can
get a half hour you can get an hour you
can get two hours you could get
more rarely three hours or four hours
but they happen six hours for a limited
series
uh eight hours is common for an entire
season
third 12 and 13 is common for an entire
season there are no more 22-hour seasons
really
and then it goes on to the next year so
you might easily get 36 hours of
storytelling on television
and a movie
you have the time
that you might need to do your work uh
if you want to spend three months or six
months or two years writing one film uh
you can do that because it's your own
unless you're being hired in other words
if you're just doing your own personal
movie
if you're being hired you're back on
your schedule again and the next episode
of
you know batman or spiderman if you're
so lucky to get on those big franchises
is due at a certain date
so it sounds like then really the only
way the artist can sort of be their own
driver and sort of work as you said in
this garrett waiting to be discovered is
an art house type film because
a television or or
tentpole movies it's a it's a collab
it's a it's by committee in a sense uh
no
actually um
yes if you want to do art house films
anybody can do that you're in the
fundraising business if you do that you
must understand
that
it is
in a sense less free because so much of
your time
is spent raising money
and then marketing
but no i think that the most
artistically creative thing you could do
is an original television series
or
even a certain series that or may not be
yours but that give you a great deal of
freedom in terms of uh
evolving the characters and the story
lines uh if you look at something like
atlanta donnie glover's show
or or you look at something like
handmaid's tale which is of course based
on a book
or any number of other things orange is
the new black
the list is long
there is
very little in the theatrical feature
arena that is as incisive
and challenging and original as some of
the work on those shows
so uh to me now this is just my own bias
i know there are people who feel
differently my own bias is that for
originality creativity
and uh exploration you really can't beat
what's happening on television now in
all of its forms if you increase it to
really all of the forms
but one maybe should test themselves how
well do they work in groups
no i mean yes yes if you're on the staff
of a show
if you're on a staff
it is collaborative that's true
if you're so fortunate as to be in a
writer's room
uh you will be around a table uh all day
every day
with uh
four or five or seven or ten or however
many you have fellow writers and
producers
um
creating material you then go off and do
your own
individual episode and bring that back
to the room
so in that sense it's a little bit like
a writer's workshop
where
yeah you get the general
structure of what you're supposed to do
for that episode in the group you go do
it
when it comes back
you're going to get notes from
collaborators
you hope and in the best shows this is
true
that these collaborators are all
building together to make your episode
shine
uh so there should be
ideally no sense of competition or
you know
tearing anybody down it's all a matter
of in service to the best possible work
and in service to the show and
ultimately yes the showrunner's vision
but not everything is is like that if
you look at the
work at uh phoebe waller bridge uh
whether that's killing eve or uh flea
bag or other things she's done
for the woman's point of view
coming alive on screen i can't think of
much anything anywhere that delivers
that quite as well as she has done with
her television series well if you look
at something like breaking bad
or or better call saul vince gilligan's
uh worlds that he has created are so
character rich
that uh it doesn't even matter if these
guys are drug pushers or criminal
lawyers or whatever uh we love them
we're rooting for them and that's that
is such a strength
uh and it comes from the writer